from sports illustrated in the mmqb my
longtime friend and former nfl media
group colleague uh none other than
albert breer back here in the rich asset
show how are you albert
i'm good rich how you doing what's your
biggest takeaway from week six so far
right now um
you know i
it's tough because i feel like we had a
couple exciting ones like carolina
minnesota and new england dallas i don't
know if there was a huge takeaway the
way
um you know what i would say i would say
like the big takeaway is that it's a
long season um you know because i i
think there are a couple teams that we
saw
early in the year and i think we all got
really excited about them and now you're
seeing them level off a little bit and
so you know now i think you're seeing
like the challenge for some of these
teams that um looked like they were
headed in the right direction so
carolina be one um i was bullish on them
at three and oh they've lost three in a
row now and you know christian mccaffrey
is hurt so
they're one um cleveland i think it's
not another obvious one they're sitting
there at three and three i don't think a
few weeks ago anybody any of us would
have seen that you know and then the
chargers really take it on the chin
yesterday
um going cross country and and and
playing a really really good baltimore
team
you know coming off of
you know i think one of the biggest ones
they've had in a couple years and
beating the browns at home and so i i'd
say that's probably my biggest blanket
takeaway is that
um you know like a lot of the teams that
we we got excited about over the first
month of the season have sort of leveled
off a little bit and you know the other
thing i think is pretty obvious you look
across the league i think we have one
undefeated team in the cardinals right
and then beyond that like i how many one
loss teams are there left baltimore
buffalo plays tonight
um there aren't a lot of them right
right
you got the you got the cowboys you got
the rams with one loss and obviously the
buccaneers just the ones yeah it's like
i mean that just feels like a relatively
small number right six teams that um are
either six now or five and one um so
it just maybe sort of speaks uh
you know i i think maybe after six weeks
we still haven't figured everything out
you know which is um which is probably
the way it is it should be no doubt
about that
um so it's amazing the obviously our our
focus in the national media changes from
week to week day to day and you know
john gruden was the story of last week
uh urban meyer came up with his first
career win
as an nfl head coach it happened in
london in a game that the jaguars came
from behind a couple of times to win um
so his job is now
are we just placing everything aside
that the khan family and urban meyer
survived all of that and that the plan
just remains the same is that the way it
goes i mean i just think you know i
honestly which i i just i like i didn't
buy that he was going to walk away
um at this point just because
i i think like the the two sides have
too much invested in one another for it
to be
to come undone that quickly right like i
know everything that happened and you
know obviously that friday night and
columbus wasn't a good one for her
permanent and
um you know the fallout from you know i
don't think that was great either um but
you know i you know i i you just have to
look at like the level of investment the
two sides had one another and that
um you know for the khan family it
wasn't just hiring a coach it was almost
like you were hiring his program his way
you know and they invested so much in
the staff and changing the way they do
sports science training and strength and
everything else
and um you know they're building a 150
million dollar practice facility uh
because he took he asked them to you
know and so there's a massive investment
um from the khan family to to bring
urban minor in there
you know and then i think what people
miss on urban is that when he left ohio
state and florida
i mean he has achieved like a high high
level of success in both those places
and so
you know i after florida was after two
national titles at ohio state was after
one
um he's never really left anywhere with
his tail between his legs you know and
it's just
you know knowing a little bit about the
guy just like i had a hard time
reckoning with the idea that he would
just
walk away that way without having done
anything you know
and so um if he completely lost the
locker room that'd be one thing because
i do think that's something he's acutely
aware of and he knows that if he loses
the locker room he's got no chance
i think absent that
um i don't think he was going to walk
away and by the way i also really don't
think he's going back to college and i
think that you know one thing people are
missing to mark on that is just i don't
think he wants to recruit anymore you
know like i don't think he wants to do
that part of the job anymore so
um i think they've to some degree
weathered the storm here and you know
that doesn't mean he's going to be there
in like 2023 i don't know that
um yeah but i don't think that there's
going to be like this quick hook with
the khan family
um you know and their handling of urban
over the next over over the course of
this season at least albert brier here
on the rich eisen show so we handled the
jacksonville side of the final london
game of the year the dolphins if it
wasn't for an ill-timed damien harris
patriot fumble in week one
the dolphins would be right next to the
lions in the winless department right
now
albert so
tua had 300 yards passing but another
loss for the dolphins and the trade
deadline is right around the corner are
you hearing anything on the desean
watson
front at all right now and what the
dolphins might be thinking on that
right now i'm not but you know i know
they've
monitored it and um
you know i you know i i think it's it's
obvious that that's something that would
have to rise to the ownership level you
know because of the sensitivity of it
um you know my guess my guess rich would
be that like there there's going to be
exploratory phone calls
one way or the other um you know between
the 42 teams that we've talked about the
eagles the dolphins the panthers
and the broncos um and and and then the
texans whether it happens from one side
or the other before the november second
trade deadline i don't think nick
casario is budging much um in in wanting
to get his price
and um you know understanding that a lot
of how his time in houston sets up is
going to be framed by what happens with
deshaun watson and what he's able to get
back for deshaun watson and i'm not sure
any of these teams are willing to pay
full price right now
so um you know i think the likelihood is
that the dolphins finish the season with
two uh to me what's so interesting about
it is
you know you look at the progress that
brian flores and chris greer made over
their first two years and now they're
taking a step back and what to me is
like worse than the step back and the
stuff that you really have to pay
attention to
is you know all these guys they had all
these all these picks they've had right
like and they
they tore the thing down right they tore
this thing down and and and and we're
going to build it back up with all these
draft picks well they drafted left
tackle out out of usc austin jackson
right now he's playing guard he moved
over to guard they got their second
round pick from this year liam
eichenberg playing left tackle
um you know they drafted a corner out of
auburn
last year in the first year and he's not
playing much they draft two uh and two
has been okay
but they drafted him in front of justin
herbert which really could leave a mark
long term on the franchise and so you
look at that and then you look at the
players they traded away and it's minka
fitzpatrick has become an all-pro in
pittsburgh and it's laramie tunzel who
may be the best left tackle in the week
for houston
and so like if i'm you know dolphins
ownership that's sort of how i'm
analyzing all this and how i'm looking
at all this
and i'm saying you know where we were
two years ago where we were three years
ago we're better off now and have they
taken all this capital they picked up
because they did a great job
like just basically accumulating capital
and have they turned it into a bunch of
good football players and i think that's
sort of how
brian flores and chris greer are going
to be evaluated going forward and the
one thing the one thing
that could change the dynamic altogether
you know and make maybe some good
players look great is bringing an elite
quarterback in there so i don't think
anybody's in the hot seat yet or
anything like that but if you come out
of this year and you're brian flores and
chris greer
and you think two is just okay
and you know you're going into year four
and you're probably not going to get a
year five if you don't make the playoffs
in year four
maybe that's where you make the move and
you try to strike with
a move for either deshawn watson or
russell wilson aaron rodgers or somebody
like that albert brie here on the rich
eisen show the zack ertz acquisition by
arizona caused me to just point out well
look at the fast dismantling
of the
eagles championship team and how you
need to win now and look around the room
and know that this is a moment in time
that you're probably not going to get
back that's what the nfl is all about
and so the question is is arizona is
this their time i mean what a win
by them yesterday without their head
coach and play caller i know you wrote
about it is this the cardinals moment in
time albert what do you think yeah i
mean i i think they're in a nice window
now um and you know they're sort of
where i mean to me it's like that rookie
contract window with a guy who's really
emerging as a franchise quarterback
where you're getting
franchise quarterback level of play from
a guy and you're paying him you know
like he's you know still a young player
and that's where the chiefs were with
mahomes and that's where the rams were
early on with golf when they were able
to spend and be really aggressive um
that's where the eagles were with carson
wentz you know when they went to super
bowl i know he didn't play but um you
know that's where they were you know
just from a team building standpoint so
the the cardinals are in that window now
and it's part of why they've been able
to be aggressive in bringing veteran
players in
and um he was just talking like vance
joseph and texting back and forth with
cliff a little last night
um it was kind of like i went back to
like conversations i had with all those
guys in the summer about how they really
felt like they were close last year
and you know one of the things that
cliffs has sort of brought up over and
over again is how
you know seven wins last year might have
been 10 or 11 as the team was better
situationally and played smarter and was
you know kind of handled itself in
winning situations better and that was
why they went out and they got jj watt
and rodney hudson and colt mccoy
um and aj green and all these guys who
you know are mature players who've been
in the league for a long time who played
for playoff teams and so you know i
think that that really showed up for
those guys over the weekend where
i mean i mean just sort of like you know
all hell breaking loose and just a weird
situation where you're going
you know i'm playing on the other side
of the country um and you're 5-0 and
you're playing against a really good
team that's
um you know coming off of a loss
and
um you know like it's maybe this spot
where you stub your toe
and i mean i think you'd argue the
cardinals instead came through with the
best performance of the season i think
for all those guys it was really a point
of pride just because
absent the head coach absent the
quarterbacks coach
absent chandler jones who you could
argue with maybe their best player
they were able to go in there and the
players were able to kind of take
ownership of the team again
and i think you saw like a real sign of
the maturity of the group which
um yeah again it has to make guys like
cliff kingsbury and steve kahn feel
really good
um to see that you know the thing that
they really look a sharp in the off
season is coming through for them albert
breer here a few more minutes left with
the scribe of the mmqb sports
illustrated right here on the rich eisen
show so much attention being paid to the
hot mic picked up of aaron rodgers
letting the soldier field fans know or
one particulars flipping in the double
bird know that he still owns them yeah
um but the sound bite that that i heard
that uh i kind of picked up on
was when he was asked about this
potentially being his last game at
soldier field he said he didn't think so
he kind of said that you know that it
wasn't maybe his last game at soldier
field which caused me to say like do the
broncos play the nfc north next year
or
could this buy the game win streak right
yeah the steelers play afc north uh i
understand next year uh you know i i'm
like
um
so my question is is like you know is
this five-game win streak showing what
everybody
thought which is like this is the best
marriage
and
the packers should just ditch whatever
about beyond the steering wheel plan
that they were hatching
in the 2020 draft and planning to turn
to at some point just screw it like
look yeah i mean is it are we there do
you think we're there
you know what rich like it's funny you
say that because i hadn't seen that
particular sound bite but i actually
like sort of the correlation that like
what kind of like came up in my i popped
in my head when i saw the video the
first time of him you know kind of like
shouting in the end zone
it was almost like
i it's weird it's like almost like a
school pride there you know what i mean
i don't know the right word
like i i i don't know the right term to
describe but almost like kind of like a
like this is a rival this is a huge
rivalry
and
i own you you know what i mean like and
it was more than just a player to me
like it kind of came off as more than
just aaron rodgers saying i always come
in here and kick your ass
it's
like we own you you know what i mean
like and it's sort of like
i my read on it was like and you could
see the way his teammates were right
there with him and it just
i mean if i'm a packer fan i'm looking
at that nice like wait a second like
that does not look like the guy who was
aloof and they couldn't find him you
know over the course of the off-season
and he's offering hawaii and you know
living the life of a celebrity like
that's a guy who looks like he's pretty
engaged in
like packers business right and packers
business is that rivalry so um yeah i
mean i think there's no question it's a
um
you know i think there's no question
like you have to feel good about that
and it was something like me and you
talked about i think in july like i mean
maybe there's part of him that's like
looking at this and saying to himself
you know what this isn't so bad we've
lost all these guys to injury and we've
still got good players out there and i'm
having another year that looks like it's
going to be a career year
and
like i i don't know i mean you know
maybe there's just that part of it where
like you know he went through
confronting exiting the place
and now he's back in the place and it's
maybe caused him to look around a little
bit more intently
and say that for all flaws
maybe there are a lot of things that are
right about the place you know what i'm
saying that's what it looks like to me
right now albert they've won five in a
row um you know and we could go
you know we can go back and forth as to
which team is the best you know i opened
the show by saying cowboys haters the
the sooner they realize the cowboys are
fielding a super bowl contending team
the better obviously the bucks are your
defending champs and brady's playing as
as well as he's ever played the rams
kept pace with arizona that you know
that's your your nfc right now the
packers have a shot to win this thing
just like anybody else certainly the
bills tonight we could go on and on but
to me it just shows again you know cobb
is playing well and that was his
maneuvering his his button push right
there and again that the exact quote is
was i i i don't know if this is my last
one
you know how you hold your feelings you
know well i i
jump in there right but i think matt
lafleur deserves credit another one too
because he's got it you know it's not
like the two of them are are learning
each other's system now this is year
three after two 13 win seasons like this
is it's kind of set up for him that's
the way it kind of looks like it's like
it's funny like when i've talked to matt
in the past about this like you know we
always laugh about like how
but the question at first was like
whether or not like the system was going
to work for him and like were they going
to butt heads and where was their
relationship and i mean as it turns out
the weird thing is is like that's the
one relationship that was like holding
this thing together you know in the
summer like that was the one
relationship that was really making this
work and i think matt did a great job of
navigating you know his relationships of
course with the people in the front
office and the people who
you know the the people who are signing
his checks
um you know with the you know
relationship he has that's the most
important relationship that he'll have
in his job which is his relationship
with this quarterback and so i think
matt's done an incredible job
um you know really kind of navigating
that and even like you bring up randall
cobb which i think is such an
interesting key
it's like a lot of coaches might have
like looked at that and said well i i
you know like that guy's washed up and
like i don't like like this was forced
on me and no i mean like matt matt like
you know pewter does like okay like this
guy makes you know you're comfortable
throwing to this guy and let's see what
he has left and they've gotten a lot out
of him you know what i mean like so like
even something like that like where it's
like you know i think some coaches maybe
their natural instinct would be to kind
of push back on a player forcing an
acquisition like that that's all in on
it and that's you know saying like no
bring him on and we'll find a way to use
him and if he makes you more comfortable
then we'll get him out there and so i
think like part of like a part of that
is like a lot of like what aaron was
looking for was like the quote-unquote
partnership right and i think in subtle
ways maybe he's getting some of those
things now in green bay and again i
think that's a great credit for the job
matt lafleur has done i mean to me you
always hear that that that term like
emotional intelligence like i think
matt's showing a lot of that in his
handling of the situation yeah the quote
was i don't think this is my last one
but i've enjoyed every single one of
them which is also
my way of saying goodbye to you albert
and this is not your last one i haven't
enjoyed every single time you've been on
the show
thank you well i appreciate it rich and
i always enjoy coming on okay albert
appreciate it thanks so much that's
albert breer the mmqb check it all out
the senior nfl reporter hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here